bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis en direct sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui notre rendez vous mensuel
avec la grande région bourgogne franche
comté et justement c'est le nom de cette
nouvelle grande région qui va nous
occuper ce matin une consultation a été
lancée pour préparer le débat du 18 mars
prochain qui proposera au premier
ministre le nom définitif de notre
région
faut-il innover faut-il regarder vers le
passé faute il ne rien changer
à quoi sert un nom de région jérémy
bonjour alignant bonjour à tous et à
écouter c'est la question nous allons
nous poser en direct avec nos invités je
vous les présente d'abord karen
patouiller vous êtes directrice d'une
agence de communication ici à dijon
également présente à paris votre coeur
de métier c'est de trouver les mots
justes vous nous direz quel est le nom
juste pour cette nouvelle grande région
selon vos critères la notoriété des
marques et la stratégie numérique
notamment également sur ce plateau
robert chapuis professeur de géographie
à l'université de dijon mais d'origine
franc comtoise
vous avez écrit notamment un ouvrage qui
s'intitule bourgogne franche comté soeur
ou rival pierre godinot est également
sur ce plateau ancien président du
conseil économique et social de
bourgogne auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
sur la décentralisation et la
régionalisation et puis vincent petit
enseignant d'histoire dans un lycée de
besançon
auteur de comment peut-on encore être
franc comtois on parlera évidemment
d'identité au cours de cette émission et
puis cette émission c'est aussi la vôtre
vous pouvez réagir nous faire part de
vos commentaires
interpeller nos invités leur poser vos
questions sur la page de l'émission sur
les sites de france 3 bourgogne et
france 3 franche comté puisque et pour
france croyez encore deux régions et
puis réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le média 6 sa fiche
lvl dfc puisque aujourd'hui c'est
bourgogne franche comté et c'est
effectivement semble-t-il ce nom
bourgogne franche comté le nom
provisoire est finalement la
juxtaposition des deux anciens noms qui
tient la corde puisque la question posée
c'est êtes-vous d'accord avec bourgogne
franche comté pierre bodineau vous venez
d'écrire un
ouvrez ce qu'ils appellent la confusion
des territoires propos de la vision est
ce que coller les deux anciens nombreux
points de vue c'est une bonne idée on
fait ça on n'en parle plus et tout ira
bien
alors l'historien vous vous dira tout de
suite on aurait pu trouver mieux
et le nom qui s'imposerait mais il ne
faut pas le prendre
c'était bourgogne avec un s parce que
très clairement il ya eu le comté de
bourgogne a eu le duché de bourgogne à
un moment donné dans un monde féodal ils
se sont réunis puis ensuite ils ont être
ils ont été séparés et puis plus tard
quand on a fait des efforts de
régionalisation on les a souvent
mélangés écrit à nouveau le choix
définitif y est décisif et définitif ça
a été de les séparer
en 1956 grâce sans doute à guer fort
mais le fait est que il y à 60 ans nous
avons décidé qu'il y aurait deux régions
aujourd'hui on fait une addition qui me
paraît un petit peu artificiel même si
elle a une logique hein mais dans le
l'ensemble du redécoupage ont fait une
addition et je pense qu'il me semble
plus raisonnable finalement de garder
l'idée qu'il ya deux régions qu'on a
fusionné et bien toutes les deux gardent
leur identité
et quand elles feront leur publicité
pour le tourisme par exemple on ne fera
pas croire qu'il y à des champs de neige
en bourgogne on dira bobonne
franche-comté bon vincent petit un choix
de raison
bourgogne franche comté je dirais plutôt
un choix par défaut
comme le dit monsieur bodineau
l'historien aurait préféré effectivement
bourgogne avait 15 ou les deux bourgogne
c'est à dire une réunification quelque
sorte de l'ancien duché et d'anciens
comptait encore que historiquement la
bourgogne actuel ne correspond pas
totalement à l'ancien duché pour la
compte et c'est vrai aussi que de ses
frais aussi quoique de nature un petit
peu moindre mais effectivement bourgogne
franche comté par défaut et puis je
pense aussi que toute innovation
même si on va la chercher dans le passé
pourrait rendre la réforme en cours plus
impopulaires qu'elles ne l'est donc je
pense qu'il faut peut-être être plus
prudents et s'en tenir là robert chapuis
le les oeufs sont faire alors finalement
se fera bourgogne franche comté il n'y a
pas de débat ça reste à la rappeuse de
ménager les susceptibilités de fait un
os qui me concerne je suis tout à fait
bourgogne franche comté et je pense que
les comtois vrai très mal une onde
région qui où la franche-comté navale
n'apparaîtrait pas un lit de bourgogne
bourgogne je pense qu'il n'accepterait
pas et je pense que ce nom va très bien
et combler deux sources le sigle bc va
très bien également
et moi je suis tout à fait pour et
entend comtois suis d'origine
je suis très pour que la franche comté
ne disparaissent pas du nombre mais
aurait préféré que la france comptait si
on m'appelle plus la région avec le
terme franche comté la franche comté va
disparaître en tant qu'aidant dread
moi je ne crois pas aux table rase et
donc je crois que le passé il est là il
faut en tenir compte les gens ils sont
sensibles et je crois qu'ils seraient
les terrains peu bêtement que de
supprimer le nom de franche comté dans
le nom de la nouvelle région salaire
quasiment acquis pour vous je rebondis
pour interroger karen patouillet qui se
spécialise la communication sur un
message qui nous a été envoyé quelqu'un
nous dit le consensus est la pire des
solutions en communication la seule
question qui vaille c'est l'efficacité
est-ce que vous avez un regard différent
de désiste au rien d sur ce service
citées cité border de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui aussi la bourgogne la
franche comté sont deux marques qui
notamment et en france et à
l'international sont particulièrement
porteuse aujourd'hui sur pan de l'art de
vie sont les gastronomies on connaît
quand même très très bien ce que
signifie la bourgogne et la franche
comté
elles ont d'ailleurs travaillé l'une et
l'autre en terme de
6 et de notoriété dans ce sens là les
deux marques se font se seront vraiment
penchés sur leur valeur sur ce qu'elle
véhicule sur la culture sur leurs atouts
moi je suis un peu surprise du côté
résigné en fait de ce débat parce que je
trouve que c'est une formidable
opportunité de garder les deux noms de
les associer de montrer en quoi ils sont
complémentaires et en quoi finalement
c'est toute la culture et l'identité
régionale qui va pouvoir rayonner quand
on gardera ses deux noms ensemble et
comme le dit monsieur avec le et sexy
dans le raccourci en tout cas qui
pourraient nous servir sur le plan
numérique pour pour communiquer sur la
communication visuelle pur bsc qui ont
filtré court donc qui peut servir à
beaucoup de choses en terme de
déclinaisons du territoire oui mais moi
je pense qu'effectivement il faut il
faut pas partie de ces enseignes
formidable opportunité en terme de
notoriété bfc vous avez les arts les opa
pdf c'est dans google par exemple dans
un moteur de recherche ont déversé n'est
pas là pour faire la notoriété il avait
ça n'existe pas on peut pas sérieusement
et séjours d'ailleurs très dramatique de
choisir ce type de ce type de raccourcis
comme nom de région on entend beaucoup
pour d'autres régions
effectivement dès voilà des acronymes on
essaie de trouver des choses qui soit
significative qui une bonne résonance et
ses sens que pour nous c'est vraiment
une erreur
la bourgogne est connu comme tel à
l'international la franche comté en tout
cas leur compte et en tout état de cause
à travailler sur sa marque elle est
aussi baissé de nous servir pour des
choses annexes type des réseaux sociaux
porter une campagne de communication par
exemple
et puis vous l'avez d'ailleurs utilisé
ce matin il peut nous servir
effectivement sur une ford pour
l'instant pour non pas s'il est pas il
n'est pas assis non plus en tant que
terre répond à la question que je vous
pose et des fc aujourd'hui c'est la
banque franco commerciales implantées à
la réunion et à mayotte aujourd'hui et
c'est aussi des entreprises qui vendent
des produits de maintenance est un
fabricant d'aérosols voilà ce qu'on
trouve aujourd'hui quand on tapait fc
dans un moteur de recherche un jeu
permet de relancer sur ce sujet de
garder les deux appellations intérieur
bernard lecomte des journalistes qui est
aussi l'ancien directeur de la
communication de la région bourgogne
à l'époque de jean pierre soisson a
écrit le maintien des deux appellations
antérieures juste à coller soulignera la
virtualité de cette fusion est ce que
vous pensez que c'est aussi une
faiblesse de dire on colle les deux
parce qu'on n'est pas capable de créer
quelque chose de nouveau car bodineau je
crois que l'histoire nous montre qu'il
faut faire très attention contre on
choisit un nouveau nom pour une
collectivité territoriale un jeu
rappelle l'exemple de georges frêche qui
avait voulu baptiser sa région qui
pourtant ne changeait pas de forme
la septimanie et n'a jamais ça n'a
jamais pris et puis je rappelle aussi
que plutôt que résignation je dirais
c'est le réalisme qui nous fait parler
parce qu'enfin on parle du nom d'une
collectivité territoriale dont les
compétences sont extrêmement précises
je sais bien c'est le développement
économique mais enfin dans une moindre
mesure
et pour le reste géré les lycées gérer
des ter tout cela c'est aussi à
destination des citoyens
je comprends bien l'idée de la faire
rayonner sur le plan international mais
précisément puisque il ya une notoriété
de la bourgogne
je pourrais citer un autre exemple
historique c'est lorsque françois
mitterrand voulait absolument qu'on
accole nivernais à bourgogne et on lui a
expliqué il en a été convaincu que
finalement vu de l'oklahoma où de new
york
la bourgogne ça disait quelque chose le
nivernais - rien du tout
à la suite de ce dont on voulait parler
dans cette émission c'est finalement à
quoi sert un nom on voulait séparer sa
d'une certaine manière entre on va dire
l'interné et l'externe
est ce que le nom il sert déjà pour les
citoyens et est-ce qu'un nouveau nonce à
un usage ça va avoir un usage par
exemple je rebondisse je continue sur ce
que je disais pour faire comprendre aux
citoyens que peut-être une nouvelle
aventure est en train de commencer parce
que de votre point de vue ça cette
utilité ou en réalité un monde un
nouveau nom oui c'est moi j'aime le coin
pain je pense effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit sont deux régions qui sont
connues et
je pense que leur addition va faire une
très belle région et je crois un un
boost figure un bout un bon titre pour
une publicité en creux quelqu'un nous
envoyer un message disant vu que les
deux régions ne s'entendent pas et ne
s'entendront pas il vaudrait mieux ne
rien faire reprendre sa liberté plus
tard plus facilement est-ce que vous
parliez de résignation tout à l'heure
est-ce que du coup un nouveau nom
saurait pas cette utilité de dire aux
gens mais ça n'est pas un pacs c'est un
mariage à partir de maintenant on est
tous ensemble en théorie peut-être mais
lequel
et puis encore une fois si on peut
espérer une appropriation jédir
populaire de la delà de la nouvelle
région il faudrait un gentil les or ces
bourguignons c'est franc comtois je vois
mal un adjectif nouveau pour qualifier
cette cette grande région en tout cas
ses habitants il n'y a pas une identité
commune aujourd'hui pour le moment moi
je ne la vois pas mais encore une fois
je pense qu'il faut aussi distinguer ce
qui relève de l'administratif et ce qui
relève de l'identitaire les régions ont
cessé d'exister entre 1790 avec la
création des départements jusqu'à 1956
ce qui n'a pas empêché la survie ou la
re création d'un sentiment
d'appartenance qu'il soit bourguignon
franc comtois ou même bressan pour citer
des régions administratives qui n'existe
pas oui moi j'avoue que 113 ça ne
m'enthousiasme pas cette notion purement
géographique là pour l'om
non seulement ça ne vient ce n'est pas
même en tant que géographe
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas chercher à
faire sans tout casser à trouver un nom
comme uniquement pour le plaisir de
changer non plus c'est vraiment pas un
objectif
moi je pense aussi que
l'identité bourgogne franche comté d une
réalité notamment sur le temps
d'enseignement supérieur à la ressert
certaines des pôles qui disent
d'ailleurs le vocable bourgogne franche
comté est assez utilisé depuis quelques
années bien avant qu'on parle de la
fusion je pense au contraire que les
deux noms ensemble ont une réalité pour
les citoyens entre les habitants de la
raison aujourd'hui
notre enjeu à mon avis il est ailleurs
c'est comment on se sert aussi de ces
exclusions pour faire rayonner
différemment que la bourgogne et la
franche comté ain internationale pour
trouver peut-être une traduction
international du nom qui nous servent
aussi dans la manière dont on est
attractif et dont on aurait
effectivement communiqué international
il ya d'autres manières de faire que de
se faire plaisir à certains endroits
voilà à koné des eaux même aller
chercher dans l'histoire des références
qui pour le coup n'aurait aucune
vraiment aucune traduction quand on vous
testera en vous pour vous d'y répondre
car audio et je me permet de rebondir
sur un terme de votre livre votre
dernier ouvrage vous parlez vous
assistez alors c'est un terme assez
connus mais deux territoires vécus
on sait que la bourgogne la franche
comté est des territoires qui sont vécus
par leurs citoyens
le nouveau territoire il n'est pas
encore vécu est ce que le nom ça peut
contribuer à sa ou pas et pour compléter
avant que vous répondiez une réaction là
sur les réseaux sociaux qui à athènes
qui nous dit on parle du passé ou de
l'avenir vécu ou à vivre oui mais moi je
suis tenté de revenir toujours à la loi
parce que bon tout ça ça nous vient de
loi et je me permettent de dire en
passant que la démocratie qu'on célèbre
pour trouver le nom des nouvelles
régions comme j'aurais aimé qu'on
utilise auparavant sur le principe même
de la fusion
un mois je crains surtout qu on aille
vers une opération en trompe l'oeil et
ça c'est une façon de répondre à la
question que vous posiez sur la façon
dont on va
justement développer nos politiques en
matière de tourisme en matière de
développement économique pour l'instant
tels que je vois les choses
il ya une politique en bourgogne et à
une politique en franche comté
par la force des choses dans les deux
années qui viennent on va continuer de
décliner ses politiques même s'il ya un
chapeau commun et comme le premier
mandat les six ans c'est normalement lac
doivent se faire l'unification des
politiques
on verra si on les fait j'ai un petit
peu peur que en permanence en face
l'équilibré entre les deux on arbitre en
permanence ce sera le rôle de la
présidence je pense est à la limite ça
peut être une politique mais ça ne sera
pas probablement celle qui va donner un
essaim un essor nouveau au développement
de la région bourgogne france-comté
d'autant plus qu'il faut appeler quand
même que nous sommes deux régions
démographiquement en situation difficile
et économiquement en situation fragile
même si nous nous crions peugeot et
enfin de la logique et plus national
gagne un gala expression pour vincent
petit vous écriviez dans votre dernier
ouvrage comment juste vous poser la
question comment justifier l'existence
d'une petite région périphérique peu
connu autant dire négligeable est-ce que
alors vous parlez de la franche comté
est ce que vous reprendriez cette
définition pour la bourgogne franche
comté qui rappelons le en démo grand
poids démographique pour économique
reste l'une des plus petites régions de
france métropolitaine
d'une certaine façon oui et on revient
toujours un problème qui est une de nos
spécialités nationales c'est celle de
l'organisation du territoire
la révolution française elle a commencé
par ça à part détruire les provinces et
construire une nouvelle structure qui
s'appelle le département et je crains
malheureusement qu'en france toute
modification du découpage territorial va
sans cesse de susciter de nouveaux
problèmes de nouveaux débats mais
effectivement pourquoi une franche comté
on n'a pas réglé sans doute un problème
de masse critique
a priori l'idée de grandes régions
auraient permis d' et en actionnant le
nom de deux petites régions on
communiquera mieux on gagnera en
notoriété pour attirer touristes
entreprises population c'est l'avenir le
dira on va demander à la commune étant
c'est tout dépend comment encore une
fois tout dépend ce qu'on ce qu'ont
raconté quels discours on m avait dit
que le nom d'un pas plus d'importance
que ça c'est pour moi non dans nos temps
tout ce que nous non encore une fois
c'est pas une histoire d'importance
ethisphere d'opportunités non non et non
des deux régions ont d'ores et déjà une
notoriété
elles ont d'ores et déjà un potentiel à
cause par exemple c'est du marketing
territorial a expliqué il ya quelques
temps que la notoriété du terme jura
était par exemple quatre fois plus
importante que celle de la franche comté
oui donc c'est pas forcément les termes
les plus porteurs et pas mais c'est pas
mais et c'est pas neutre non plus on
veut en sortir la franche comté du nom
et en misant sur la bourgogne qu'on va
pouvoir porter l'identité du terme de
2,2 du jura et de ce que effectivement
de livres fin l'écosystème qu'offre le
jura en termes d'attractivité
derrière il faut exploiter toutes les
potentialités des deux noms et moi c'est
pour ça vraiment que je défends encore
une fois le fait de les garder c'est que
je pense qu'effectivement les deux
identités régionales sont très fortes en
termes de notoriété pour des raisons
très différentes notamment la bourgogne
là on a le vin on a roulé avec les
maillots et autres choses
et puis et la france font pas aussi
aussi vraiment travailler sur ses atouts
et décidera quand on est effectivement
quand effectivement un pour moi vraiment
ça dépend encore encore une fois comment
on choisit communiqué et la manière dont
on mettra l'accent sur certains atouts
sont nos valeurs sur la culture sur
l'identité sur nos potentiels et nos
points forts d'attractivité sera
vraiment faim sera la communication
région est ce que votre point de vue il
faut mettre en avant le fait que vous
l'avez beaucoup dit pierre bodineau on
est des régions qui ont été mariées
séparer remarier re se préparer est ce
que le fait qu'ils aient une histoire
parce qu'elle est en réalité on sait
bien qui a une histoire commune entre
bourgogne franche comté énormément de
familles ont des parties de famille en
bourgogne en franche-comté des gens sont
allés travailler merci des gens font
aller travailler sont revenus
c'est des régions qui sont assesseurs
est ce que votre point de vue il faut
s'appuyer là dessus
ou est-ce que c'est terminé il faut
aller vers l'avant regarder leur front
va proposer maintenant l'avant en chacun
sont deux à tours il était question de
faire table rase effectivement de de ce
qui existe et ce qui fait nos forces
pour autant je pense qu'il faut il faut
pas forcément aller chercher dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire de la non
justement pas justement pas mais les
deux points sont un point fort de
l'exercice et régionales il faut aller
chercher ses points forts là pour les
faire exister à l'international est
pendante sans quoi l'écosystème de
bourgogne franche comté de vrai
potentiel de rayonnement et c'est en ça
je vous dis qu'il faut regarder vers
l'avenir mais évidemment l'avenir est
bâti sur le passé vous disiez tout à
l'heure ce sont des raisons qui sont
victimes elles sont vécues dans tous les
sens du terme
encore une fois on a la chance d'avoir
vraiment des atouts sur pan de l'art de
vivre de la gastronomie et la culture
qui sont très fort maintenant il faut
savoir comment va les valoriser et se
pense pas que le débat se résume au nom
de la région
ça veut dire vous voulez rebondir oui
une petite remarque en passant
l'historien remarquera aussi que les
ducs de bourgogne leur notoriété à la
grande époque des valois c'était
essentiellement aux territoires du nord
qui le donnait un leurre qui souvenir
est beaucoup plus important c'est donc
un regard était bourguignon absolument
devient complice des changes aujourd'hui
ce serait bien non simplement je
voudrais rappeler qu'il ya quand même
une autre faiblesse quand on regarde les
réformes
elle apparaît aux yeux c'est que on a
beaucoup dit que la réforme jouait sur
le couple métropole région bon nous
sommes avec la région centre la seule
région qui n'a pas de métropole
alors on en vient à la taille critique
voilà je connais la réponse c'est oui
mais nous avons deux capitales dijon et
besançon
est ce que c'est vraiment un avantage
d'avoir deux capitales je crois pas
franchement eu au réseau de villes d une
vue de l'esprit un qu'on puisse mieux
faire travailler ensemble et 1500 qu'un
petit peu de sirop et a chanté un air
très fort moteur économique n'est pas à
besançon mais qu'ils aient le temps de
l'enfant
frappé par la formule utilisée par la
préfète
quand elle présente les réformes
administratives qui consiste à dire la
plupart des administrations régionales
maintenant ce sont des administrations
sur deux sites
parce que effectivement les
fonctionnaires restent à dijon ou à
besançon
donc on voit bien qu un fonctionnement
sur deux sites
c'est perpétuellement un fonctionnement
compliqué et je me dis en passant à bien
voilà un des aspects de la réforme c'est
à dire la simplification je parle pas
ici des économies c'est un autre
problème
il n'a pas véritablement bonjour je vous
envoie la reverser puis on disait de
région soeur je le disais tout à l'heure
vous être l'auteur d'un ouvrage sa roue
rival bourgogne franche comté vous avez
la réponse finale à cette question parce
qu'il ya toujours cette rivalité on l'a
vu cette semaine pour l'implantation du
tribunal de commerce spécialisé il reste
une rivalité qui n'a absolument pas
disparu avec la fusion tu as fait
d'accord mais je pense que la rivalité
peut être positive
c'est en décision et c'est là bas je le
crois moi et je pense que les comtois
qui font pour le moment un peu un
complexe d'infériorité faut bien il faut
bien le dire et non pas de raison parce
que ils ont des atouts et je pense
qu'ils peuvent très bien tiré leur
épingle du jeu et je pense que moi au
contraire une scène qu'on va dire
concurrence de jouer une saine émulation
ça peut être excellent pour la pour la
nouvelle région
et j'ajouterai que ces deux régions d
atout fantastique et je dirais alors
j'ai peut être fâché des comtois mais
d'un côté la culture de l'autre côté la
nature sont quand même deux termes qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne bien
votre voisin trois petits
sur les campagnes de communication
derrière de comment faire ce travail si
vous permet de parier sur l'identité
comtoise
c'est assez typique d'une construction
qui date essentiellement du xixème
siècle du romantisme avec l'idée d'une
franche comté agreste
protégé par ses forêts ses montagnes
alors que la bourgogne c'est des jolies
collines viticoles donc issu du travail
des hommes
il ya aussi je pense que dans ces
histoires de d'identité il ya toujours
cesser ces questions symboliques qui
sont extrêmement fortes et là l'image
mentale delà de la région telle qu'on se
la fait voilà et la haute-saône n'est
pas forcément un territoire montagneux
et et forestiers mais quand on parle de
la franche comté on intègre des régions
en a sous un vocable il ne connaît
aucune question en fait robert bodineau
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
démocratie sur le pierre bodineau pardon
de démocratie sur le la fusion se
cherchait un nom c'est effectivement
réfléchir à son identité
est-ce que de votre point de vue
n'aurait pas mieux valu qu'on commence
par ça avant de la faire la fusion il
resterait pas été une bonne façon pour
les bourguignons les francs comtois de
se l'approprier cette fusion de
réfléchir finalement à ce moment et à ce
qu'ils étaient gagne pas tout y est
c'est une bonne idée ça aurait été beau
l'idée de faire avant votre médecin en
terme de toutes les régions et
rationnelle je vois pas bien comment
c'est à dire que tout le monde aurait
répondu qu'il était bien c'est lui c'est
une bonne réponse aux questions que
disent d'ailleurs très majoritairement
les gens aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux terre pourquoi j'ai envie de
dire que ce n'est peut-être pas un banc
dans une franche comté que le problème
se pose avec le plus de temps avec le
plus critique semble t'il donc je suis
pas sûr pour le coup il ya une décision
qui est de nature politique et est
aujourd'hui à traduire dans le
dans le quotidien effectivement
d'administratifs et de l'économie ce
centre on y est donc les riffs il faut
effectivement pas se demander si on doit
y aller en tout état de cause
encore une fois je pense que l'identité
de bourgogne franche comté à une réalité
il faut maintenant on exploiter toutes
les potentialités c'est par exemple une
démission ont fait remarquer que dans le
monde du bridge il existe depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années le comité de
bridge de bourgogne franche comté ne
s'arrache pas bien il ya de multiples
coopération qui existe depuis des
lustres et c'est ça qui devrait inciter
à la réflexion pourquoi ce qui a si bien
marché pour les banques pour la carsat
pourquoi à un moment donné ça s'arrête
personnellement c'était un petit peu la
conclusion de monsieur chapuis et c'est
ce que nous avions constaté en faisant
travailler ensemble les deux conseils
économiques et sociaux régionaux c'est
que si on avait continué sur la voie
d'une coopération de plus en plus
étroite
on aurait préparé le terrain bien mieux
je ne pense pas qu'on aurait levé
nécessairement toutes les inquiétudes
que soulèvent ce qui est quand même
disons le franchement une fusion
administrative et une fusion politique
quand je dis politique je veux dire
institutionnels mort politique étatique
ils nous demandent si est-ce que ça va
le nouveau nom a changé quelque chose
sur le plan économique
et quand même rapport la compétence
principale des futurs grands contenants
peinture avec une question go qui émane
est bourgogne aussi les plus urgents de
créer des emplois que de perdre du temps
sur un an
oui vous êtes plutôt d'abord l'action
oui mais je crois que non c'est
important je crois que de nom c'est
important et il faut pas négliger ce qui
est logique ce qui est dans la tête des
gens je pense en particulier au comptoir
mais aussi bourrignon je veux c'est
important le nom il faut pas le défaut
et il faut y réfléchir à une pâle bradés
alors il nous reste 2 minutes 30 avant
les infos midi on va commencer à vous
avons proposé des noms on va revenir
serez choses qu'on a dites bien sûr mais
en commençant par là la dimension
historique
est-ce que d'abord bourguignon tout
qu'on est ce que bourgogne tout court ça
a été le cas à une époque ce serait une
bonne idée ou alors les bourgogne ont
alors beaucoup comtoise on a tous voila
tout ce qui est fasciné deux identités
régionales à mon sens on a pour le coup
comme vous le disiez mêlant savent même
que leur région s'est appelée comté de
bourgogne d'accord à une certaine époque
donc que ce serait pas plus simple est
ce que parce qu'on raccourcirait et du
coup pour le mieux lorsque le bourgogne
franche comté sanaa vous dites c'est un
bon choix par défaut mais ça aussi
défoncé l'ontt et lycées dont mais on
est prêt si c'est les débats dans
d'autres régions si vous regardez un peu
ce qui se fait en europe est ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
ce sont alors qu'il ya une vraie
effectivement une vraie emprise du nord
sur le nom de la région et son fils or
ce sont les gens qui habitent dans nord
pas de calais qui vous disent ne
supprimant pas la guerre dit et je pense
qu'il faut être aussi et
nord-pas-de-calais le nom de la région
pas que le nom des deux départements en
plus donc là on est dans le même
dans même écosystème je pense pas que
les bourguignons le souhait de voir
disparaître la franche-comté - adriano
nous signale la comté c'est d'abord le
pays des hobbits
on a aussi le mandat je pense que c'est
pour rigoler qu'autre chose c'est pour
les anglo saxons est ce que dans la
dimension historique burgondie c'est
quoi ni des choses qui renvoie alors là
vraiment à jules césar
les historiens on sombre dans
l'archéologie simplicité c'est quelque
chose qui soit effectivement
compréhensible internationale et dont la
traduction anglaise puis s'en va pour le
mieux
c'est un argument aux lettres les
langues de façon que comptait faire pour
autre chose là falloir changer la taille
de nos maisons c'est comme ça on va
rajouter que je le pouvais rajouter que
jura pour les anglo saxons c'est aussi
une île écossaise ont fait du whisky
faut au moins autant qu'une montagne et
que jura en géographie ça sert pour
d'autres montagnes que dura français le
jura souabe ou le jura suisse
voilà il nous reste une vingtaine de
secondes avant les informations me dis
donc on va s'arrêter là on continuera
tout à l'heure avec avec d'autres noms
qui vous nous direz aussi vous vraiment
à la fin de cette émission
de votre point de vue ce que devra être
le nom de cette nouvelle région le
rappelle il ya une consultation en cours
et le nom sera proposé au premier
ministre se dit s'il était que que les
choses vont se décanter
quelques informations dans nos deux
régions et on se retrouve juste après
tout de suite